welcome to this five-minute game playing
blue one but us is like another venko
problem young it seems to be very
popular among American players the van
Gogh okay now before naylet that's
uncommon but not bad I mean why not let
some consider should I go a form and
maybe and a three I mean sorry or just
developed me on let's develop use this
possibility to play Bishop to be to know
probably best to get this closed all it
takes that's a that's a surprise that's
a surprise or in the scepter should
favor wide really now and every move
dashed out instantly it's just giving
away upon for a fuzzy bear dip don't
know why okay so i can even play Bishop
c3 here sent the Queen back maybe and
now he cannot even develop here
yeah that's the airborne and it's not
going away let's see here to a one on
you might exchange the bishop I on c3
yourself I probably should give it some
support by the a pond and now let's see
i guess i should clarify this just to
simplify matters I came the question is
how exactly am I going to play here I am
I need to exchange that's no big choice
there I could can let him take but don't
think this changes so much okay
yeah it's not it's a there are many ways
to try to improve the important thing is
he won't get 35 porn I mean there's no
way is going to maneuver night to be
seven and capture it I said we'd see
that happening the question is however
how am I going to to to win this without
allowing too much counter play yeah
that's it's a very good obviously but
the bishop on d3 is not a great piece it
should be improved one ideas push-ups
e2a for not sure that I can actually
manage that I don't think so I'm trying
to prepare rugby one get this rook excha
the Sun rook exchange there probably
something I should do
okay yeah if I take it yeah not so much
choice I probably must take it let's see
here well a six-year is probably going
to take
I probably need to get rid of this night
assume it's too too much for
passionately only five and now
yeah probably here getting a five
getting if Ivan it's not just the poem
on a five I mean look at the center
green tea too well you can play okay
let's just let's just take it no switch
over to the Kings side between 85 this
Queen f5 just going for King cytotec now
and there's still the a poll I mean it's
don't think you can easily defend
against the attack and keep the porn
okay time morning probably yeah I don't
know so i can give this chick here so
long check
43 seconds that's not not not very much
now like as a guest completely busted
but it's still not going to be a matter
of just a couple of moves one threat to
Snyder five-year probably in connection
with d6
it takes Queen the 8's are quite strong
check check yeah Queen g7 is also the
Shakya that sets that's unfortunate he's
so coloring it he's covering it from me
five year that that's really unlucky
John so this will will be tough with the
time you Brigid himself out of that that
lost position check yeah that's in law
unfortunately f5f won the draw let's
lose this it's okay check check check
check black for fits on time gif of5 is
just the draw not sure what he did that
here fiber for is just the draw he's
writing to me what did I do wrong about
the opening is lost from lack had played
it I didn't play a gentle well he and
this in the scenario white can certainly
can certainly win but i didn't i didn't
find it yeah just green age five I guess
yes that is the easiest just get the
pawn you know it's not it's not so
self-evident have widest winning here
because the bonus is blocked i mean the
computer as on plus three and that's
probably correct but then it's still
somewhat tricky haha created here Kia
Quincy to it's very clean on h7 yeah
yeah not not not a great game but what I
still never understand this how you in
the opening at it and understand it
simply I'm always amazed how can you
play a four and three seconds it
basically loses the game you're not
going to get get the spawn back ever
ever and white white is basically
winning here this is not a regular benko
the apron is the extra pony or not yeah
it it just it's just a pawn for nothing
and this is not helping as well all this
but ok in blitz you can play all kinds
of stuff and get away with it you'd get
away with it because the opponent is
making mistakes as well and I spoil this
plus five position to to to this I mean
the main problem is that i played this
one which
I I simply didn't I didn't get that
after King h7 I cannot take on f7 um
here here you can still get here played
this and win a try that's still pretty
much winning but just bad play check and
here this this is just a draw this
position and it yeah maybe wider why
this might could maybe try him I was
this 19 seconds own Associated try to
exchange it down to a draw to make it
easier to play until of course he just
plays a 45 and it's a draw I haven't
even seen four but this just promotes
the pawn and wins and wins easily
alright thanks for watching